me
none
[音楽]
早速なんですけど
皆さんあのごはん食べている時に目の前に美味しそうな小籠包が一つだけ余っていると
しますそれ食べますか
それともなんかこう他の人が食べたいんじゃないかと思って手を出せないですか
なんかこういう場面ってたぶん誰もが経験したことあると思うんですね
僕らの日常の生活の中にはこういった様々な選択をする場面っていうのがあります
思ったことを言葉にするなんか頭ではわかってるんですけどなかなかこう
いざ言おうと思ったら言えないとかそんなことってありますよね勇気を出して人に
伝えるってなかなか難しいです
タイミングがこう上手くなんか分からなくて伝えられないとか
あと空気読まないと嫌われちゃうんじゃないかとか
また困難ですから波風を立てない方がいいんじゃないのとか思ってついつい講演料し
ちゃいます
だからさまざまな不安っていうのが僕たちの中にはありますで僕自身もそういうことを
感じるときがあります
僕は8ここ札幌で生まれ育ちました
でまぁ3歳になる頃にはもうクリエイティブディレクターの
こっちが目覚めてたんですけど
16歳でアメリカに留学しましたアメリカに行ったばかりのときは自分の思ったことと
かやりたいことを全然伝えられなくて数々の挫折とか
後悔とか経験しました
だから今僕はできるだけこう思ったこととかやりたいことを人に伝えるようにしてます
さっきの小籠包の話だと思う食べるよ止めてパクって食べたり
これ食べないのとか人に勧めるとかとにかく何か怖い店に対して伝えるようにしてます
でまぁそんな効果以外の経験とかで学んだことの1つに
思ったことを言わないのは思っていないのと同じということがあります
これあの決してこわがままなろうよとか
めちゃくちゃなことを言ってくださいということではないです
あくまでも自分の思いを相手に伝えないともったいないよっていう風にとらえて
ください
体なんか例えばこう僕だったらこうするのになぁとか
なんかこうやり方わからないから教えてとか
まあシンプルなことで言うとありがとうとかごめんねっていうことをちゃんと相手に
言っていくっていうことが大事だと僕は思ってます
で僕はフナーの先ほどご紹介していただいたんですが
広告のクリエイターとして働いています
広告のクリエイターってあーこの様々な企業や
社会の課題を
解決するそんな仕事ですまぁちょっと交互歩クリエイターと聞くとキラキラしててなん
かこう
自由にものづくりしてるっていうイメージ持たれる方もいるかもしれないんですけど
と地下鉄塔結構いろんな制限とかルールとか
約束の中でものづくりをするっていう高日々格闘している
もがき苦しみながらものづくりをしている
そんな毎日を過ごしています
制限やルールですね僕たちの生活のなかにはたくさんあります
時間とか
お金とかマット体力とかリソースみたいな人間の部分もあります
こういったものと日々格闘しながら僕たちはこの世界を前に動かしています
僕もそういった制限があると
突き抜けた表現をしようとか今まで誰も見たことないものを作ろうみたいなことが
難しくなったり
時にできなくなってしまいます
なのでそんな
壁を突破するために僕はあるものを作っています
それが野望リストというものです
野望リストは
広告等が想像するあらゆる
やりたいことっていうのをとにかくひたすら書きま苦労っていうリストです
だがこんなことやりたいあんなことやりたいというのを書きまくりますそしてそれを
仲間に共有しますそこがすごく大事です
えっと僕たちがこう思っているやりたいことというのはとにかく書いて共有する
とってもシンプルで誰にでもできることなんですけど
めちゃくちゃパワフルなツールになります
で実際に僕がその野望リストを活用した例というのをちょっと紹介しながらお話しさせ
てもらいます
それが8パラ卓球って言うから卓球協会のお仕事ですパラ卓球協会の仕事はロゴの
デザインとポスターのデザインっていう
マートでも規模としては小さい
ないものでした
予算も潤沢にいなかったので本当に小さい小さい
仕事として始まりました
パラ卓球はあのたような障害を持つ選手たちが集まっていて
例えば右てない選手の右側攻めるとか左足ない選手の左側覚めるみたいな
結構お互いの弱点を攻めまくるみたいなことを選手が言うんですけど
でもそのお互いの弱点を攻めるっていうのが
海底のリスペクトスポーツマンシップなんだというふうに同時に選手の人たちが言って
いて
僕たちもそのスポーツを初めて知った時にすごく感激しましたそしてすごい強いなって
思いました
僕たちその
卓球をプレイするその障害者アスリートの生涯て個性だなって思ったんですね
それをなんかこう上手くみんなに伝える
向集団はないかと思って
この変形卓球台というアイディアにたどり着きました
変形卓球台っていうのはそれぞれの選手が6
感じてる見えているその生涯を通して見ている
卓球の世界を卓球の第4子変形させてスケッチにすることで表現したデザイン
アイディアです
実際にこう説明すると一番左の八木選手ですね
わーっと生まれつきてが短い選手で
てが短い分ボールに手が届かないんでその分彼はこう
ダイナ周りを走り回らなきゃいけないですね
なので僕の代はこう丸く大きくなっていて人一倍走り回るなきゃいけない
脱臼をしているとか
真ん中の岩渕店主は
左足が
あの障害があって弱い分高1の左足に踏み込むと左側に踏み込むと踏ん張りが利かない
んで右に戻りにくいだから僕の大学を左側が大きく
出てる台をかけました
一番右のちゃった選手は
車椅子の選手なんですけど車いすに座っていると
卓球のネットまで
手が届かないんで
がこんなが感じるって言ってたんですねそれで彼女はこういう大を書きました
という風に
この
パラ卓球の変形台というのは選手のチャレンジが
乗り越えようとしているチャレンジが一目でわかるから卓球の見せ方としては今までに
ないものとなりました
僕らがこう活動を進めていくうちにどんどん家ボリスとっていうのを膨らんでいったん
ですね僕たちやりたいことをとにかく書きまくりました
例えばま
ポスターを
1枚作ろうというところから始まったのを選手20人の形がある過去20枚作りたい
ねーとか
あ投稿
名刺にしてみたら面白いねとかこれリーフレットにしたらいろんな所において僕たちが
説明しなくても広がるんじゃないのとか
的ついにはこれ卓球台実際に作ったらどんな体型になるんだろうと
途方もない荒野某いっぱい書き続けました
実際にこの卓球台なんて作ったことないんでやり方わからないけどとりあえずちょっと
書いて
だかやってみようよっていう風に
僕たちは進み続けました
で僕らの子の野望リストというものは僕たちのこの挑戦の道しるべとして
僕たちを導いてくれるものとなりました
実際に
卓球台作り始めようと言っても何をどうすればいいのか全然わかんなくて
とりあえず後段ボール切って行ってみようとか
あのいろいろ手探りでやってたんですけど
彼のやっぱりこう自分たちの思いを発信していくうちに
沢山のパラタッキーを応援してくれる人たちが
僕たちをサポートしてくれました本当に大勢の人が助けてくれました
そして次に僕たちはこの3台の卓球台を作ることができました
それがこれです
実際にあの tokyo 2020の公式台を作っているメーカーさんの全面協力で
あの
競技用の台と同じような造りを変形させたという作り手にしてみるとかなり無茶ぶり
だったのかなって思うんですけどあの僕たち結構
これやりましたやりましょうみたいな感じでいろいろ思ったことを言ってそれが形に
なりました
一番下のあの土台の部分が
オリジナルの高サイズは違うんですけどオリジナルの卓球
テーブルの天板のプロポーションになっていてそれがこう徐々に上に行くにつれて
選手の個性を表現している天板の形に変化していくというちょっとストーリー性のある
なアートとしても
5見応えのある作品に美しく仕上げ用と頑張ります
僕たちこの卓球台を作った後もまだまだたくさんの挑戦は続きました
例えばこのイベントとか10時とかにもほとんどんだそうよという風にチームで話した
んですねでも
搬入とか搬出みたいのって自分たちで
4トントラック手配して自分でこう1個250キロもあるんですけどそれを3台
真夜中に運び込む作業とかをして僕たちの挑戦を続けましたしかも1回とか2回じゃ
なくても何十回もこれやりました
全部自分たちで
作業をしました
ええっと僕たちその野望リストに書いたからといって
もちろん全部実現したわけではないです
あの実現しどころか何していいかわかんないものとかもいっぱいありますでもそれでも
書き続けました
例えばテレビ局にテレビで取材してもらえませんかっていうリコ見に行ったんですけど
あのパラッツォポーズだけだとちょっと視聴率取れないねとか言われて断られたりした
こともあります
あとなんかこうスポーツ文脈じゃなくてアウト文脈で見せられないかと思って美術館
展示したいなーとかっていう野望あるんですけどちょっとどこから始めていいかなーっ
ていうのがまだわからなかったりもします
でもそれでも僕はいいと思ってますあのどんどん野望リストに項目をつけたしていく
ことというのが大事だったり想像を膨らませる事っていうのが重要だと思っています
で
結構中には時間がたったら
あの前はできなかったんだけど
なんかこういつのまにかできるようになってたみたいなこともあるんで
大事なのはそのリストに自分のやりたいことをちゃんと改定で誰かに共有するという
ことが大事だと思います
このプロジェクトはロゴデザインとポスターを1枚作るというところから始まったん
ですが
第ができたことによって本当にたくさんの人に
パラスポーツの魅力を届けることができました
子供から大人までいろいろな人に実際に見て触れてもらってパラ卓球の魅力っていうの
を知ってもらいました
て好選手と実際に触れ合う機会が台を作ったことによっててきたんで
あの
なんかこう戦車へのリスペクトみたいなものをすごく子供たちが感じやすくなったん
ですね
それってやっぱりプロロゴデザインとかポスターデザインだけでは絶対にこう到達でき
なかったとこだと思うので本当に大が作れてよかったなと思っています
僕たちが小屋某リストに書いたことが実現した
おかげでここまで来れ
なのかなと思っています
って思ったこと言わないのは
思っていないのと同じ
なんかこう思ったことを伝えてこそ意味があるのかなと思います
思ったことを口にすることっていうのは人を動かすパワーになります
時に図々しく僕は図々しくてもいいと思ってます
なんかこう自分がワクワクする気持ちを人にシェアするということが何かの始まりに
なったりすると思います
これ食べていいとか食べないのとか
まずはそんな小さな野望からぜひ始めてみてください
今日はありがとうございましたあ
[拍手]